اخبار الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه بايجاز
من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى اهلا بكم المجازر
الاسرائيليه تتواصل لليوم ال طيران
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقصف مباني لمدنيين
في مخيم المغازي وسط غزه في مجزره راح
ضحيتها عشرات الشهداء اغلبهم نساء واطفال
ووزاره الصحه تقول ان اسرائيل ارتكبت 1031
مجزره ادت الى استشهاد 9000
170 منذ بدايه
الحرب وزير اسرائيلي يقول ان احد الحلول
المطروحه هي القاء قنبله ال نوويه على غزه
وان مقتل الاسرى قد يكون من اثمان هذه
الحرب ونتنياهو يوقفه عن العمل ويقول ان
كلامه منفصل عن الواقع اما الناطق باسم
حركه حماس فقال ان هذه التصريحات تعكس ما
وصفه بالارهاب الصهيوني الاجرامي غير
المسبوق تائب القسام تقول ان مقاتليها
يخوضون اشتباكات شمال غرب غزه وتؤكد قتل
عدد من القوات الاسرائيليه وتدمير دبابات
بقذائف الياسين والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن
مقتل جندي في معارك غزه مما يرفع عدد
جنوده القتلى الى 30 منذ بدايه العمليه
البريه رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري
يقول ان اسرائيل تغولت بارتكاب اباده
جماعيه وتطهير عرقي في غزه وينتقد
المعايير المزدوجه للمجتمع الدولي وبايدن
يؤكد ان هناك جهودا لاعلان هدنه انسانيه
في غزه ووزير الدفاع الايراني يحذر واشنطن
من ضرر بالغ ان لم يتوقف العدوان
الاسرائيلي الى
اللقاء